F of g of 5 equals 30. Great problem solving if you found this answer. Remember
when we find the f of g of 5, you really want to find g of 5 first. We want to
find the output for g, when the input is 5. Then we take that output and we
plug in that the input for f. So to find g of 5, we simply take 5 and plug it
in here. So we'll have 5 plus 5, which we know is 10. So, the g of 5 equals 10.
In other words, the output of the function g, when x equals 5, is 10. So now
that we know this entire value, we can replace g of 5 with 10. Now we can just
find f of 10. You want to find the output of the function f when x equals 10. I
can remember that f was my tripling function. So, I'll have 3 times 10 or 30.
So, we know the f of g of 5 equals 30. Our answer.